the homeless are now the biggest source
of guests for many new york hotels
rehoused here in the pandemic it's
offered more space and safety than
typical shelters
but drug and mental health issues among
some make it a complex
picture and six months on it's creating
tension
in manhattan neighborhoods i know many
people on this block
will not go out at night they will not
go out after seven
not just at night marisa rodante
describes how rife drug abuse is making
many
areas feel unsafe her frustration
directed at the city authorities this is
a war
this is a war against so many elements
that have been mismanaged by our city
that it has created an apocalyptic
crisis
i mean when you say apocalyptic describe
that well um you know there are days
when you will see some of it you'll see
this much of it where we feel
that even walking on the street to get
groceries
you have to be aware all the time people
have been
hit doing nothing and and knocked out
come dusk there's a steady stream of
ambulances responding to problems
one resident contacted sky news to share
the scenes outside his home
139 hotels in new york are now housing
the homeless
and some of the shelter residents like
james also have concerns
it's a refreshing thing to have your own
space and stuff like that i just wish
that everybody else in a situation would
see it the same way you know yeah
yeah some people just they take
advantage of it they just
you know what i'm saying and you hear
the house the debates
say it they're like some people don't
their rooms are disgusting and i
understand i understand
so it's uh it's a it's a messed up
situation i feel like i feel like it's a
messed up situation on both ends i mean
you know certain people don't belong in
a shelter let's just be honest certain
people don't belong on a shelter some
people have mental illness some people
have
a lot of other things and they i feel
like they need to evaluate better
this is a 600 room hotel which is now
a shelter across the road another 600
room hotel which is also housing
the homeless and it's impacting the
neighborhood residents who can get out
have left
businesses are struggling to operate if
they've even reopened
and the toughest thing perhaps is that
they don't know
how long this is going to go on for
nearly nine in ten restaurants and bars
in new york have been struggling
to pay their rent as a fourth generation
of his family business
paul is determined to stay open in our
neighborhood we've always had
several houses shelters more than
most neighborhoods in new york
that is the perfect example of what's
going on
in our neighborhood you don't totally
know
you're a little you know nervous and the
tensions are a little high
many businesses that closed six months
ago now won't reopen
when the hilton times square shuts for
good you know the problems are big
the city is crying out for custom and
visitors
forget international travel you cannot
come to new york city
from 35 different states that's
essentially the entire united states
so in the past when we had crises like
say 9 11 or the great recession at least
other americans came here
and to see it like this cut off from the
rest of the world cut off from the rest
of the united states
is just heart-wrenching
funding to house the vulnerable is
helping some hotels
survive this crisis in the city that
never sleeps
remains unclear when the crowds and
tourists will return
sally lockwood sky news new york